we are going to begin in ukraine with
the increasing isolation of russia's
president vladimir putin following his
invasion of the country he now says he
is putting russia's nuclear forces into
quote special combat readiness end quote
an explicit threat to any nation helping
ukraine and there are a lot of them he's
also created a domestic crisis for
himself as russian currency plunges in
economic value due to the sanctions
they've got real bite and as we speak
russian forces are still battling to
take over ukraine's biggest cities but
so far they have failed the much smaller
ukrainian forces have held them off and
now the two countries are talking for
the first time since the invasion
charlie daggett is in ukraine's capital
kiev that's one of the cities under
siege right now charlie good morning
what can you tell us
good morning those crisis talks got
underway earlier today here in ukraine
you may be seeing one of the first
images of the meeting taking place
ukrainian delegation is demanding an
immediate
cease-fire ukraine's army says it fought
off attempts by russian forces to storm
the outskirts of the capital overnight
but generally it's been quieter here in
the city than in the past few nights
ukrainian troops fight running street
battles with russian forces fierce urban
combat fending off their advance in what
has become a key battleground ukraine's
second city of kharkiv they picked
through what's left of a destroyed
russian convoy stopped dead in its
tracks with ukraine claiming to have
stalled the offensive president vladimir
putin ordered defense chiefs to put the
country's nuclear weapons on high alert
out gunned and outnumbered ukrainian
soldiers and civilians alike are
mounting a stiff resistance through
determination and defiance videos shared
on social media show citizens standing
up a group of unarmed men blocking the
way of tanks shouting nobody wants war
go home another man seen kneeling in
front of a tank
a driver mocks stranded russian soldiers
who have run out of fuel pulling up
alongside and offering to tow them back
to russia
but these are dark days between the
aerial bombardment a three mile long
convoy of russian reinforcements masked
outside the capitol and now belarus
reportedly preparing to join the fight
keeve is a city under pressure
this morning city officials lifted a
lockdown that's been in place since
saturday evening but they warned there's
fighting in almost every district in the
city only leave your homes in case of an
emergency
and getting food is an emergency when
you don't know when the next lockdown or
round of missiles will come
it is dangerous to come out is this
dangerous to stay at home it is
it is less dangerous to hide in the
bombing shelter but we hid in the
bombing shelter for
you know for 24 hours residents here
desperately want to believe there will
be a breakthrough but they're digging in
and preparing for what's to come and
even while delegations talk peace the
war rages on
president vladimir zelinsky says he's
skeptical about peace talks currently
underway saying he doesn't really
believe in an outcome but he added if
there was any chance to end the war
ukraine should be part of it
nate
charlie dagger and keith thank you